I looks Pakistan anyway you know because
our family over there a huge fan base
over there after winning the fight I
always go there to Pakistan and then I
heard what happened in the shower
obviously I want to go that show my
respects go to the school and also help
rebuild a school again I mean innocent
children were killed and you know it
shot the whole world what happened there
so obviously me being a British
Pakistani I wanted to go out there and
show my respect do you understand how
Pakistan is could do that well you know
what it's very sad to I mean we don't
know who exactly did it i mean is very
sight with what someone could yummies
you know i just cannot believe so one
can even think of doing something like
that and over hundred the eternal killed
and very sad I mean everyone impacts on
I'm very upset when the world they've
all upset and because just can't believe
someone couldn't even do anything like
yeah but we've seen other events the
attack on malala of course the other
terror attacks within Pakistan and
Afghanistan why is it do you think that
this this is happening well you don't
know I'm even a white happen I think you
know the people who did it I mean we
don't know who they are just yet but
they really need I mean the people who
are involved in this will need to be
punished here's a kid to do anything to
anyone I mean they were just go to I've
got little girl myself who you know
who's all introduce only someone so but
imagine me I'm sending at school and
then finding this finding out that you
know if you were killed in school I mean
just heartbreaking I mean I cannot just
believe what the parents are going to be
going through they must be really in a
lot of pain but I mean whoever did you
know I should be punished and I think
it's just really buddies putting pucks
I'm very backwards back and also just
scaring a lot of kids to go back to
school I mean it and let you know the
kid in the future and it's messing
things up for them people often say who
carry out these attacks or who support
them that the attackers are acting in
the name of religion somehow well you
know be me being a Muslim myself I mean
it never says that you're in the Quran
it never says you kill innocent people
so like I said we don't know exactly
did it I mean not something that you
know I think should come be coming out
very soon when I was then applies I'll
speak to Army Staff Raheel Sharif and he
did Sarah you know to getting very close
to finding out who plotted this thing
and who will behind it all but the thing
is I mean look in the Quran being a
Muslim it doesn't teach you to go and
kill him some people i mean how did you
feel when for example those men who kill
people in Paris say they've avenged the
Prophet I mean it's very sickening first
of all can I mean killing innocent
people again in Paris you know innocent
people killed and I think it's just
wrong you know I condemn them and I
think it's just very sad to hear stuff
like this is happening okay is it right
to take offense at depicting the Prophet
let alone depicting the Prophet
satirically well I think disrespecting
is is one thing you know I think it's
wrong what things are being done I mean
you know what what I've been said I mean
look is just I think people just can sit
there like so we don't need all this
drama and we don't need all the killings
and shootings and stuff I'm sure it can
be solved in different ways for what
people are doing i think the wrong way
taking their own man but there is always
this question of the extent to which in
Western society your british-born you
should bend over to respect what other
people say is their religious
observances and there well definitely I
think in every religion you know what my
parents taught me when I was a young
child you know was to respect everyone
and don't matter what religion Dean what
color they are solvay respecting each
other and obviously that's what I'm
going to be teaching my little girl
might as well and to respect everyone
and respect every religion but I think
that's the way to move forward everyone
should begin on with each of them
expecting each other that way I don't
think we'll happy we'll be having any
problems but if you say respecting me
means not doing something or stopping
someone else doing something that's
where the problem starts isn't it I mean
that's exactly that's what the problem
start is when when when you know you're
you're saying something so on and they
did they do something different I mean I
think they just need people to send this
message across
need role models to follow and people to
look up to I think that way they're
gonna you know go the right way and
follow the right path how do you think
we in the West and obviously for answers
on people's mind at the moment but but
what do we need to do to put an end to
this to stop these sort of dreadful
attacks happening I think to put a stop
to something like this I think we need
the world leaders to sit down together
and you know we need them to talk
through all these and you know like site
to improve security as well and whoever
you know in our eyes we think are doing
bad things and i'm killing innocent
people i think we should definitely put
a stop to them and you know i mean i
think this is all by sitting together
communicating i think that's what is the
lack of communication isn't there
nothing that's why there's so many
people that were suffering because of
that reason and you obviously feel that
people such as yourself world-class
sportsman do have a responsibility as
role models yes you know me being a
world-class boxer I think gives me a
little bit responsibility also being a
British on a pakistani so you know with
me saying something i think it might go
a long way of a lot of young kids who
follow me to look up to me I'm like a
role model to a lot of people so you
know me same things I didn't need more
people like myself you know to send the
right messages around the world